Kissing,
clickings sputtering.
These are just some of the odd sounds that people around the world actually used
to speak.
Come here,
these unusual phonemes.
Try them out yourself and find out which one of them is something you say every
day in English.
Weird sounds in world languages,
not my normal fair,
but I'm feeling something light.
Before we get into more linguistic tails,
let's go.
A row of language is all lined up in Africa.
I have a sound written good ba GB,
so when you've run across this name of a dance from the Cote d'Ivoire,
you might be tempted to go French on it and call it good big debate,
but notice that tie on the top.
It's one single sound to make it bring your tongue up to the soft palate and
make a go,
but also clothes and release your lips during that Gulf for a Combo Gubba sound,
but make me,
there's a voiceless form to pay in the world.
Atlas of language structures with its cross language data on common and uncommon
sounds.
These are rare enough that they're only an 8% of the language is sampled.
Can you putter your lips like if you're cold,
but that's a bilabial trill.
Phonetically speaking,
don't pat yourself on the back for it though.
A number of languages use blue and blue sounds,
but in the far reaches of Brazil,
deepen the Amazon lived the Pieta,
Huh?
People whose language has stirred up some linguistic controversy.
One of its unusual features is a bilabial trilled affricate to make it,
they hold their tongue in position for a t sound against the thethe.
Then release it with that sputtering lip trill.
So
I see why the sound is rare.
Try this next type of sound might be more familiar to some of you out there for
angels.
The pharynx is straighten the back of your mouth where the nasal cavity connects
to the throat,
connects to the voice box.
If you bring the base,
the root of the tongue way back,
the restricted airflow makes this sound.
Yeah.
Am I breathing here?
This isn't creepy at all.
Voice that sound and it's aw.
Aw.
Do you know which major world language has sounds close to both of these and
expects you to tell them apart from nearby?
Glottal hun Vilar,
it's Arabic and other Aphrodisiac languages in all for NGLs can be found in only
4% of the languages in that world.
Sample
a Spanish.
I landed in the canaries off the coast of Africa.
Logo Meta makes him intriguing noises,
unlike the previous examples there,
oddity isn't us sound.
It's actually a whole way of speaking using whistles.
It's called as CBOE,
the whistle by locals who use high or low frequency combined with either flows
or breaks and communicate both vowels and consonants.
The West that
lippy trill in Brazil for NGLs in Semitic.
So far our rares are clustered in hot zones,
but this next rarity is found all around the planet.
Prepare your tongue for dental fricatives.
You won't really need much practice though because English has them
putting the tongue up against the teeth and pushing a stream of air flow around
it.
This way is only done in a somewhat over 7% of that world language sample.
Horrified English.
You know how French is infamous for its nasal sounds?
The whole hall French got them when a nosy sounds spread.
One val over that happens,
but nasal spreading doesn't have to stop there,
spread away through vowels,
through consonants,
until whole stretches of sounds become downright infected with the nasal,
like in the [inaudible] language of Colombia,
we're seeing a suit comes out as seeing awesome.
Lots of odd consonants so far,
but I found some fun valves along a river in Wahaca,
Mexico in a town where they speak a must,
a tech language for everyone.
Normal value,
give them,
they have three for you.
Normal,
which link was called modal voice,
but also breathy voice.
Ah,
and creaky voice.
they even do this with nasals.
Ah,
ah,
AH,
add to this that they also have tones.
All these continents you've never tried to tell apart and even their own whistle
speech and you've got yourself a mouthful.
One last one before we go.
Time for the audit speech sounds out there making their home in the southwest of
Africa are the Koyczan languages.
This isn't a single family even though mess comparison struck again,
it's a cluster of families renowned for possessing entire sets of sounds,
cold clicks.
This is a kiss.
I mean a bilabial click kind of even.
It looks like a kiss to make it speakers,
close their tongue against the back of the mouth and also close both lips,
but don't purse them to closures.
Then using the tongue,
they suck a pocket of air into that enclosed area.
Finally,
they let go of the lips and out pops up trapping air between two closures and
then releasing.
The front closure can be applied to your teeth,
the side of your mouth,
the roof of your mouth.
So much clicking click languages accounted for just 1.8% of that world language
sample.
Well,
see,
our world's languages are full of all kinds of meaningful,
strange sounds.
Maybe we'll take a linguistic trip to one of these hotspots and investigate
further.
Until then,
stick around at subscribe for language.